okay so this is good this is promising
we're making progress because these
these are the terms uh
one two and three that are in the result
that i'm trying to prove so that's
promising
but uh i'm not done yet right there's
this extra stuff flying around
for starters if you look back at um the
result we're trying to prove
i've got 2 pi over 9 i've got 4 pi and 9
i've got 8 pi on 9.
there's no 6 pi on 9 term that's the
first issue
and the second issue is on the left-hand
side of what i'm trying to get to
there's a polynomial of degree
6. but i i don't have a polynomial
degree 6. i have a
polynomial degree 9 right so i still
have some work to do before this result
can be considered
proven so to make that work a bit easier
and also the rest of my results what i'm
going to do is just introduce a few
labels
because as you can see this is very
already getting very long to write i've
got the entire line taken up okay
so here's some labels that i'm going to
introduce every time
you see cos 2 pi or 9 i'm going to write
that as c2
which is just let's see is my
abbreviation for cos of something
pi on 9. this is c2 that'll make this c4
that makes this c that should say c8
actually which is a bit
of an oversight of mine let's fix that
over there
there we go now you'll notice i haven't
done that for this this term in here
c6 i haven't named it that because cos
of 6 pi or 9
i can simplify that to cos 2 pi on 3 and
that's an exact value that i know
so this accounts for y in the result i'm
trying to prove there are no 6 pi or 9
terms because you can just
evaluate them okay so now that i've
introduced these new labels c2
c4 and c8 and i'm also going to simplify
this
what happens well the next line shows
you
what happens as i simplify out right i'm
going to leave the left hand side for a
moment we'll come back to it shortly but
this z minus 1 nothing's happened to it
i've just substituted this term
for c2 right and there um this term i've
just written a c4 you can see how much
more concise this
is you've got c8 hanging out on the ntr
correctly thankfully in this line
but i want you to pay close attention to
what's happening in here what's what's
going on
keep on changing this by accident oh i
think i changed this whole thing
let's uh that's better that's why i keep
doing that all right so let's have a
look at what's going on in here
so in this case what you've got is um
two lots two lots of cos six pi nine
which we already established is the same
as cos two pi
three that's minus a half negative a
half so you got minus two
times minus a half that's just equal to
one so this minus two cos six pi on nine
z take a breath that just gives you
z so that's why this term this
expression in here
is equivalent to this expression in here
this factor
okay now this is really useful to me
right because this helps me to do
some simplification um these factors
here
one two and three they are in the result
that i'm trying
to prove so they should stay put they
shouldn't go anywhere right
but this term in here let's underline it
z minus one
and this z squared plus z plus one they
are nowhere to be seen
in this result that i am supposed to be
proving they don't belong at all
so somehow i've got to get rid of them
and i've also got to change what's
happening on the left hand side
so how do i go about doing that well
what i want you to notice is
you can actually take this z minus one
and this z squared plus z plus one
and you can combine them in a familiar
way this is actually a factorization
maybe you recognize because we've used
it not that not that long ago right
if you multiply z minus 1 by z squared
plus z
plus 1 this is actually the difference
of cubes so you can see me taking these
two terms in here and combining them
into z cubed minus one if you i'm not
convinced that that is true just go
ahead
multiply all these terms by z then
multiply them all by minus one and then
when you collect like terms
convince yourself that you will indeed
end up with z cubed minus
one okay now this is really good we've
made progress
but how does this relate to you know i i
meant to get this result on the left
hand side
which is a polynomial of degree six z to
the 6
6 plus z cubed plus 1. so
clearly there's going to have to be some
simplification over here and the clue is
what we just did
we just did this factorization here or
we we expanded actually
expanded got rid of brackets to make
this into a difference of cubes
we can do the same thing on the left
hand side this is also
a difference of cubes it just doesn't
look like that at the moment so i would
rewrite z to the power of 9
as thinking about my index laws it's z
cubed
cubed that's z to the power of nine
right that
take away one that's well one is also
one
cubed so you can see now beyond the
shadow of a doubt this term here
from z to the minus one this is a
difference of cubes so what is the
factorization of this
going to look like well um i'm going to
have the same kind of factorization that
i had over here
and here except instead of z minus 1
it's going to be
z cubed minus 1. instead of z squared
it's going to be z
cubed squared and then instead of z it's
going to be z cubed that's what i've got
here
so that was a lot to take in let me just
write it slowly
you're going to get out the front z
cubed minus 1.
and then you're going to get z cubed
squared which is z to the 6 then you're
going to get z
cubed and then you're going to get 1.
hopefully that
looks familiar so you can see what i can
do here
is that this z cubed minus 1 and this x
cubed minus 1
clearly i can divide both sides by these
things and it will cancel
and that is what lands me with this on
the
left hand side and then just z to the 6
plus z
cubed plus 1 on the left hand side this
is the result i was after so i'm just
going to say that
as required okay
how are you doing so far we've had to
cover a lot of ground
um we've used our you know some some
basic trig to expand what's going on in
polar form and to
um simplify out you know some of these
terms in here we had to do a lot of
algebraic sort of gymnastics to get to
here um your difference of cubes
result is um is really important here
and then we end up with
this polynomial of degree 6.